we start with an egregious example of
just fake phony fraudulent news as
always
just when you thought it just couldn't
get any worse
well think again in its ongoing effort
to smear slander besmirch destroy the
president of the united states well you
have your media mob
reporting a completely false story and
in the process putting people's lives in
danger
likely outing the real identity of and
home address of a spy
working for the c.i.a now jim shiuto
is a former obama administration
official he's masquerading now as
fake news cnn's chief national
correspondent oh
let's see obama straight to fake news
cnn
let's see lying and leaking straight to
fake news cnn
oh likely guilty of lying and leaking
straight to fake news cnn
anyway reporting he reported a
high-level spy was extracted from
russia in 2017 by the way spying on
our behalf for quote concerns of
president trump and his administration
repeatedly mishandled classified
intelligence and could contribute to
exposing the covert sources of spy well
that's a lie that was fake news
again in fact this claim by fake news
cnn was contradicted by both the
washington post and even the new york
times
the times reporting quote former
intelligence officials said there was no
public evidence and mr trump directly
endangered the source
and other current american officials
insisted that the media scrutiny of the
agency sources
alone was the impetus for the extraction
oh the media was responsible reporting
from the media
the mob not donald trump but the media
mob
all based on leaks from the intel
community now
that was the reason for the extraction
in fact in 2016 under obama the cia
first offered to extract this source
because of the media's reporting
but there's more and it doesn't have
anything to do with president trump
late 2016 as a vindictive welcome
and a gift to the incoming
administration than president obama
he declassified and publicly released
the dni report on russian interference
which inadvertently alluded to this
spies role in the kremlin now
russian interference it all happened on
obama's watch now didn't it
i wonder why that important fact that
didn't make cnn
fake news's headline and in a rare move
this rarely happens
a c i a spokesperson called cnn's
narrative simply false
and secretary of state former cia
director mike pompeo
he weighed in a strong way calling the
story material and
materially inaccurate let's take a look
the reporting is materially inaccurate
and you should know as a pharmacy
director i don't talk about things like
this very often it is
only the occasions when there's
something that i think puts
people at risk or the reporting is so
egregious as to create enormous risks
the united states america that i even
comment in the way that i just did
and i won't say anything more about it i
know the ca put out a statement
uh suffice to say that the the reporting
there is factually wrong
i gotta ask yourself tonight now is cnn
fake news president jeff
zucker proud of this political hit job
putting
a operative's life in danger oh to help
obama sycophant this guy jim schutto
whoever he is
and does anyone on fake news cnn or
let's see
msdnc the conspiracy channel they
actually care about the truth
of anyone anymore now despite all these
glaring errors
in this reporting this bs reporting the
two networks they dedicated
hours and hours of breathless hysterical
coverage once again
to what was an outright lie watch this
we've also learned and this is a cnn
exclusive that u.s intelligence pulled a
very high level agent to spy
out of russia in part out of concern the
president might somehow blow this
individual's cover
partly because of the way the president
mishandled classified intelligence
in part because of fears that trump the
president of the united states
trump could expose the spy through his
mishandling of classified information
the cia extracted the spy in part
because of fears that president trump
might leak information
about the spy to russians including
possibly vladimir putin
of course some of the very worst
coverage parroted by
nbc's chief conspiracy theorist yes
roswell rachel maddow and as per usual
her reporting was downright theatrical
and yeah just like hang on i got the tax
returns
he paid 35 million in tax i got the tax
returns
take a look what the cnn report is
saying is that and now
nbc news and new york times matching it
as well
is that as president trump so
egregiously mishandled classified
information
and in so doing destroyed highly
sensitive highly effective foreign
intelligence operations
by telling the russians about them that
u.s intelligence decided that president
trump
might burn america's best source inside
the russian government
now in their obsessive coverage of this
story roswell rachel maddow her
conspiracy channel and news division nbc
news they further exposed
think about this the extracted spy i
wonder if roswell rachel rachel's going
to apologize for putting this man and
his family in jeopardy because
yes msdnc basically in
arma propaganda for the dnc they tracked
down
this guy's home address they actually
knocked on his door
and the reporter was then approached by
a parent of security that rolled up in a
black suv now keep in mind
you know putin has developed you know
the hostile actor that we always
tell you about on this program the guy
that we can bring to his knees if we be
energy independent now producing with
gas and oil that guy
the hostile regime well that guy right
there putin has developed quite the
reputation for murdering
double agents all over the world
including the united kingdom
that doesn't seem to matter to the media
mob now does it let me make this clear
with this fake news mob what these
conspiracy theorists did here
now it's great it didn't take two and a
half years to expose this huge
lie hoax and conspiracy but what they
did here is put this guy's
family and his life in danger why
well only they can answer and then of
course you have the obama administration
that created this disaster
seems like the predicate is what it
always is hate trump every second every
minute every
hour of any 24-hour day every week every
month every year
and tonight the life of an important cia
asset who is risking his life the whole
time
is much more at risk